in the movie shock starring this man
opens in theaters Friday and September
22nd good to see you Noah why thank you
sir nice to be here welcome to the the
program it's great to be here and I was
just saying in the break that being here
is gonna give me some serious street
cred it was my 14 year old son who's the
biggest fan of the show is that right
yet no I told him I was going on it is
like dad you what wait dad you know that
you're gonna have to talk about sports
right I know a little about sports he
goes well like in the 80s we we talk we
can talk sports in the 80s as well like
you said that you can't eat it up you do
December I was there at the Rose Bowl
when the Steelers beat the Rams and Lynn
Swann cut those four touchdown passes
beaten Vince Ferragamo right now that's
right Vince Ferragamo I remember being
so excited just to show you how my my
world of sports and pop culture always
crosses I once got so excited I saw
Vince Ferragamo on the Hollywood Squares
once that he was an actual square and
like all this sports gathers Vince
Ferragamo
that's Fran Tarkenton you did well I
mean he's was that's incredible right
right it was incredible with him and Joe
Namath on the Brady Bunch that was
another crossover at all that was huge
because if I'm not mistaken that was the
famed Brady Bunch episode not to play
ball in the house that's right right see
Owen now would always say who's Joe
Namath who's Vince Ferragamo
no he's encyclopedic my son I don't you
know now that everybody carries a pocket
computer in their hand and it's not
quite like studying the back of your
baseball card that I did when I okay
okay he is more savvy about this stuff
and maybe it's the fantasy league that
he plays and it's it's required reading
to know these stats chapter and verse so
he's very hit well you never know cuz I
had my teenage age nephews here a couple
of weeks ago and they stopped by here
the the show they walk through the
hallway that you walk through when you
came here and we got photographs of some
guests who were here before they went
they pointed to Kevin Costner and asked
their dad why is the general manager
from draft day on the
I know how to sit my nephew's down like
little uncle rich time let me talk to
you about Kevin Costner that's good they
haven't seen Field of Dreams yet they
definitely haven't seen Bull Durham yet
you know that I would yeah what is your
favorite sports movie no oh my god you
gotta choose no why there's such a
sucker form but if I had to pick one
which you usually have to do in the
situation yes I go with the natural the
natural to me is a absolutely perfect
movie now you were reading a Philip Roth
book in the back so you would definitely
know that that's a book with Mel Mel oh
yeah I have it but I actually think it's
one of those strange cases where the
books good and the movies great I I just
think that movie is flawless it is great
yeah you know we're captures everything
that you love about baseball as a kid
all that wish fulfillment all that the
dream of a promise unrealized and
getting a second crack at it everything
yeah I know and Wilford Brimley is the
manager man test Richard Farnsworth has
to be a coach and then Robert Duvall is
the the awful as the sports writer awful
medium and always put the media like
that I don't understand him Basinger oh
yes in Glenn Close standing yeah hell of
a cast oh I believe that was maybe her
second film after GARP
well yeah and then and then and then I'm
just Noah Wyle here on the Rich Eisen
show if if you had her like an old
baseball card collection which one still
have it let's go to my card sitting so
what's your what card Dodgers were Steve
Garvey Davey Lopes
Bill Russell Ron Cey Dusty Baker Kenny
Lando Rick Monday Steve Yeager behind
the plate behind the plate and then on a
mound Scioscia came in soon thereafter
on the mound Gary Royce Burt Hooton Bob
Welch fernando's Don SOT Don Sutton
absolutely before he went to the extras
so now how old are you 46 ok I'm 48 so
I'm a kid sitting in New York City fired
up that Reggie Jackson's hitting three
home runs in the 1977 World sketch that
Craig Nettles made going horizontal
derive Steve Garvey a what would have
absolutely been an extra base in was one
of the daggers to my heart and the fact
that they put that photograph on the
cover of Sports Illustrated that week
yeah which I had a young subscription to
right healed me even further no kid
so the 81 World Series where Fernando
and the Dodgers took care of Righetti
and the Yankees and that ended Reggie
Jackson's Yankee career that was that
was great pretty sweet although I'm one
of the few people that in California
actually bought an 8 Reggie bars do you
remember when they came in with the
ridge was great it was it was like
chocolate and there's Rice Krispies and
cabinets it was a bunch of stuff all
like underneath the melted em pile yeah
they threw Reggie bars it in one day
yeah what happened to this sports fan
Noah I don't know
acting is that what happened in your 14
year old saying you know maybe I was an
avid sports fan until uh around March
17th 1993 when I walked into a
soundstage on the Warner Brothers line
started making er and turning out 80
hour weeks for the next 15 years and
that was the end of that and then
somewhere in that period of time I
became a father and that took over and
then I managed to sort of winnow all my
sports interest down to just Laker
basketball which I managed to hang on
through all through the Kobe Shaq years
oh now
yeah even now although this is a really
kind of a very interesting traditional
time for the Lakers well I mean you got
Lonzo ball coming in and that's the the
I mean this town feels like he is the
second coming I don't know if they're
buying what lavars picking up or putting
down yeah I've been wrong before but I
tend to think of the Lakers is always
being a center dominated team and when
the Lakers are always at their best yes
it's either Chamberlain or Jabbar or
O'Neal and we will we wanted white
Howard to work we wanted Andrew Bynum to
work but I feel like we've been a sort
of holding pattern waiting for that big
center spot to get filled even though
the game is changing total style the
game has changed
you know the Warriors don't need a
center in that traditional sense that
you're talking about right now no but I
don't know maybe it's just part of the
culture I grew up with I feel like that
anchors us in a way Noah Wyle here on
the Rich Eisen show so its Clooney's a
big sports fan easy huge Bengals fans
you know football fan and Reds you know
I grew up the Big Red Machine so there
was no sports talk on the set of ER that
didn't happen oh yeah we talk sports
he had NBA aspirations as a kid as did I
we both were you know he was a out there
bankers backyard shooting baskets like
I'm Kentucky right yeah yeah absolutely
right
so you versus Clooney one on one what do
we had two moves imagine he still does
but it's been a while since I've played
him he can shoot the lights up from the
top of the key that I mean so Susie
takes the ball and he's just raining him
she's a chucker he's a chump what do you
do you step out on that no you put your
hand up and then he does this little
left-handed layup this little scoop shot
but I'm a big gangly guy I've got arms
like Abraham Lincoln and I swear I
couldn't watch this thing yeah I
couldn't find it mmm those two shots mmm
were the death of speaking of shot
that's your new movie that's Friday
September 22nd tell me about this the
nice movie little movie it'll be enjoyed
by dozens it was one of those things
that come your way and you think to
yourself I like what this movie has to
say moreover I like the challenge it
will present to me I have been working
in television for a really long time
which is financially very lucrative and
occasionally creatively rewarding but
there's also a great breeding ground for
bad habits if you're an actor and it's
easy to get lazy so every once in a
while I try to tackle a project that
just scares the piss out of me and I
knew that after being a doctor for 15
years how uncomfortable just to be the
patient and I knew that this movie was
gonna be about me laying on a gurney and
getting poked and prodded the movies
called shot it's about a guy gets shot
and it's a realistic look at how one
single bullet can change the lives of
everybody that's involved not just the
perpetrator and the victim but everybody
involved and so I wanted to challenge
myself and make myself as uncomfortable
as I possibly could and I accomplished
all that and again that's in shot opens
in theaters Friday September 22nd and
you were great in falling skies which I
recall personally for me is my one and
done experience being a reality
competition host I was the host of The
Great Escape on TNT
Falling Skies was our leading and we
held hardly any of that audience thus I
was one and done as a reality
competition host on TNT so I wanted to
personally thank you for the ratings I
was unable to hold so I couldn't hold on
to a mother no
that's not true that's not true at all
and then a few good men yes sir what in
the world was that experience like how
old were you when you were in that set
that I would have been let's see that
was 1992 1992 which we came out he won
we shouted I would have been 20 years
old I had never shaved my head before I
was playing a lot of pickup basketball
in city of Park in Hollywood and I
remember the day I shaved my head
everybody treated me differently when
that pickup game everybody used to beat
the hell out of me in that game suddenly
I showed up with this high-end type
marine cut and they wouldn't come
anywhere near me it was like this one
window where I was you know hey where's
your head I was a Jonas with you and
they didn't want to mess with me right
um but I was the low man on that totem
pole that totem pole was Tom Cruise Demi
Moore Kevin Pollak Kevin Bacon he went
on down the list Jack Nicholson and I
was talking about happy to be on the
club I was just there so was Nicholson
around the set when you were there or we
overlapped one day we didn't have any
scenes together but I know we're in the
same courtroom together
I remember the table read through you
know table read through czar this sort
of informal gathering where everybody
reads the screenplay out loud for the
first time right and it's really kind of
like just just throwing it out there not
you're not trying and that was the
energy as it began and as soon as Jack
Nicholson began to read his part he gave
the performance that he gave in the
movie that day and as soon as you spoke
it was like everybody today went oh
we're really doing this and it just went
from here to here and I remember
thinking at 20 years old this is what
pro-ball feels like you know I've I've
been around a little bit but I hadn't
been on an all-star team before and this
is what it felt like playing with people
who speak in shorthand to each other and
know their job so well that they're
painting with really fine brushstrokes
and pin drop right be a printer totally
dangly no he was it was masterful that
and I spent a lot of time on that movie
because I figured out he came to work at
10:00 and he rapped at 5:00 and he got
paid I don't know five million dollars
and he was only on it for two weeks
so I'd spend out in my head I think how
much does he make per second how much
like if he spends 30 seconds peeing how
much did that
dumb games you're both Laker fans huge
Laker fans yeah
lock-in he sat down here I said on the
team so now you go home and you tell
Owen Wiley you you you did very well on
the rich man show yes you will be
youtubing it no doubt you gotta fight
very good good to see you know you got a
shot in theaters on Friday September
22nd Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
video be sure to download our app and
I'll be sure to move week six games to
Saturday for that wedding you have to go
to